let's go the sponsors of this next
segment their purpose is more than just
sharing food they're here to help you
and your business too here's how
[Music]
welcome to cisco las vegas my name is
andy van willigan i'm the culinary
specialist here cisco is the largest
food distributor in the world providing
businesses with products and operating
solutions for their businesses our
purpose is connecting the world to share
food and care for one another for
example if you're a restaurant out there
that needs any of these products
we have them available for you
the great thing about our cutting edge
solutions is we just don't have one
product that goes to one customer our
our products can actually be utilized
across the board for example these
pulled oats over here you can utilize
them in tacos in pasta anything like
that with the cauliflower tortillas also
the pulled chicken you could utilize it
in a cold chicken sandwich in tacos into
your soup into enchiladas into a
barbecued chicken sandwich so really it
goes with all genres and our last but
not least we have an amazing caramel
apple cheesecake that really could just
go everywhere in addition to our cutting
edge solutions we have in-house business
reviews and off-site business reviews so
in-house business reviews we really
bring the
people in we can make menus for them
we'll cook the food up for them
test out products we'll maybe do a
cutting of you know maybe five or six
different types of bacon so they can
choose and pick what they'd like
off-site we can go and
kind of see problems that are in their
restaurants and help them fix things so
really we're a resource that i don't
think any other food distributor has and
really business reviews are for new or
potential customers if someone wants to
be a potential customer you really just
need to you know call cisco we'll send
out a rep we'll sit down and have a
meeting and then we'll fill out some
paperwork you know cisco has many of its
own branded items we have over 20
different brands from dairy to produce
chemicals
we even have something called supplies
on the fly where um you can get
equipment you know for your restaurant
if you're opening something you know we
we can support you across the board and
you know really sometimes the branding
is exactly like like a
for instance a ketchup versus a ketchup
we're exactly the same but cheaper and
we can help you out in that way vegas
restaurants are opening back up and we
really want to support the community and
be behind them you know we're even
starting to deliver six days a week to
be able to support smaller restaurants
you know that don't have a lot of space
and you know we just really want to get
behind people and make vegas strong
again
thanks to cisco foods for sponsoring
this segment for more information give
them a call at
702-632-1800 or visit cisco.com